what's up guys i'm dave klein aka dave
control and welcome back to my spoiler
filled elden ring lore series today
we'll talk about a fierce warrior
represented by the red lion whose power
could stop the very stars today we
discuss star scourge radan and the red
main warriors
radon was born of two separate houses
his mother was ranala of karyn royalty
and the master of the academy of reya
lucaria giving him an association with
intelligence and sorcery meanwhile his
father was ratigan who was a champion of
the archery and the golden order with an
association to incantations and faith
radigan had flowing red hair that radon
would inherit
every giant is red of hair and ratigan
was said to have despised his own red
locks perhaps that was a curse of their
kind
however while ratigan seemed to compare
this to the giants who fought against
the golden order and archery and
therefore saw it as a negative radon
viewed this as a positive thing
radon inherited the furious flaming red
hair of his father radigan and is fond
of its heroic implications i was born a
champion's cub now i am the lord of the
battlefields lion
while radigan compared his hair to that
of the giants it would seem radon
specifically compared his to a lion with
lions having a stronger association with
america's former husband godfrey the
first elden lord godfrey was a ferocious
warrior when he vowed to become a lord
he took the beast region suraj upon his
back to suppress the ceaseless lust for
battle that raged within
in fact radon even went as far as to
design his armor to represent godfrey
the golden lion is said to symbolize
godfrey the elden lord and his beast
region suraj from his youngest years
radon was naturally captivated by the
lord of the battlefield
after all if radon loved warfare in
battle godfrey was truly the best and
someone to idolize he was known as the
lord of the battlefield and his soldiers
were never known to have lost a battle
lord godfrey at last at the end of his
campaign his golden armies unvanquished
and unbowed
meanwhile all we really know about
radigan radon's father in battle is that
he was unable to conquer ranala and
instead took up a political alliance
through marriage which on the surface
was out of love especially on the part
of ranala but it's unclear for radigan's
part this was out of love or out of
politics
barrier of gold was used by the
champions of the earth tree in the first
and second liurinian wars during which
the red-haired ratigan joined the heroes
ranks as there was a first and second in
the iranian war to me that implies that
ratigan didn't win the first of them and
therefore a political alliance might
make more sense if he
again wasn't winning the second he came
to these lands at the head of a great
golden host
when he met lady ranala in battle
he soon repented his territorial
aggressions there
and became husband to the karyan queen
so this could be why a young war and
battle obsessed radon could be so
fascinated with godfrey specifically
after all godfrey was a legendary figure
something notable that i glazed over
earlier was the item description about
ratigan's red hair
every giant is red of hair which comes
from the giant's red braid item
description an item you can only acquire
by trading in the fire giant's
remembrance
so it bears the question of if ratigan
is related to these giants after all his
son radon is notably quite giant in
stature so if radon inherited his red
hair from radigan he could have also
inherited this trait which would explain
radon's massive size
of course radigan isn't a giant but he
could be related and just skip those
genes or been a runt of the litter
at some point in radon's childhood or
adulthood ratigan left ranala to marry
queen america however
when godfrey first elden lord was
hounded from the lands between
radigan left rinala to return to the
earth tree capital becoming queen
america's second husband and king
consort
taking the title of second elden lord
all of this gets more convoluted when
you throw into the mixture that radigan
is america including the fact america is
a newman so that does throw my idea
about radon being related to giants into
question but it's all something i
definitely want to discuss in a future
video but for the purposes of this video
the main point is that because the rest
of the world viewed radon's father as
marrying america that meant radon now
had the status of stepchild or step
demigod radhan was amongst the children
of renal and ratigan who became
demigod's stepchildren after ratigan's
union with queen america
as radon was born to ranala it stands to
reason that he probably grew up in karya
manor khari and ranala who specifically
are known for their association with the
moon and not necessarily the stars and
as he was a son of a sorcery-involved
family he eventually left to study in
celia town of sorcery located in caled
here he studied gravity magic under the
alabaster lords
the red lion general wielded
gravitational powers which he learned in
celia during his younger days also he
would never have to abandon his beloved
but scrawny steed thanks to zuli the
witch who was able to dig into the npc
ai scripts of eldon ring zully was able
to discover this beloved steed of radons
is named leonard so radon being a man of
action devoted himself to studying
gravitational magic at least in his
youth so he could ride leonard despite
how massive he himself was the alabaster
lords who radon studied under were one
of the magic building races who had
arrived in the lands between via the
stars aka some sort of celestial body
like a meteorite striking the earth and
bringing life with it the alabaster
lords are race of ancients with skin of
stone who were said to have risen to
life when a meteor struck long ago
i find it interesting that they aren't
the only celestial beings using
gravitational magic with the beings
known as aston also known for
gravitational magic as well as the
falling star beasts which draws the
question of if there's a relationship
between the three
either way clearly the alabaster lords
were on good enough terms with celia to
teach gravitational powers there whereas
in karya an alabaster lord can be found
locked inside a royal grave ever jail
the onyx lords who had skin of stone and
were called lords in reverential fear of
their destructive power
considering how terrifying these lords
were considered to be that could make it
an even greater achievement that radon
chose to study under them and came away
learning plenty of gravitational spells
in particular he learned collapsing
stars gravity well and rock sling all of
which were a gravitational technique
mastered by the young radon i thank you
for your tutelage for now i can
challenge the stars
while radon had learned gravitational
magic to at least in part be able to
ride his steed there was a further goal
one that would earn him the nickname of
starscourge radon would challenge the
very stars utilizing his gravitational
magic and prevent more comets and
meteorites with more celestial beings
from falling from the sky
the mightiest hero of the demigods
confronted the falling stars alone and
thus did he crush them his conquest
stealing the very fate of the stars
general
is the conqueror of the stars
who stood up to the swirling
constellations halting their movement in
a smashing victory but long ago general
radar challenged the swirling
constellations
and in a crushing victory arrested their
cycles
now he is the force that repulses the
stars radon earned considerable renown
as the star scourge in his youth and is
said that it was during this time he
engraved the gravity crest upon these
blades
an interesting thing the question is why
radon challenged the stars we know for
certain a couple things for one objects
from outer space like comets carry with
it all kinds of celestial beings and
other worldly consequences
estelle who destroyed the eternal city
came from the stars the alabaster lords
falling star beasts and probably even
crystallines came from the stars even
the elden beast which set in motion the
archery and golden order came from the
stars it is said that long ago the
greater will sent a golden star bearing
a beast into the lands between which
would later become the elden ring for
two by stopping the cycle of the stars
radon has prevented irani from being
able to complete her quest of
challenging the greater will and two
fingers and has prevented her from
beginning an age of stars
so ronnie's fate is kept in stasis by
stars ghost radar
so that leaves a few possibilities in my
mind it could be as simple as star
scourge radon who so greatly admired
godfrey in all of his victories
challenged the stars as a means to take
on an even greater foe and show how
mighty he was
it could be that as he was born of
ratigan he might hold some alliance to
the urgery and is preventing
lovecraftian beings sent from competing
otherworldly gods from arriving to the
lands between so the greater will can
continue to reign
or perhaps he knows the stars are tied
to ronnie's fate and is trying to
prevent an age of stars and ronnie from
taking over if general radan were to die
the stars would resume their movement
that said he does have a moon dial at
redmayne castle which i take to be a
symbol of sorcerers and those interested
in astrology so i find it unlikely plus
there's the fact that he became
starskers in his youth likely before
ronnie had godwin killed so it could be
as simple as this was an unintended
consequence i'm honestly not sure which
of these it could be and i'd love to
hear your theories in the comments
personally i'm leaning towards the first
of these that radon simply wanted to
challenge a great foe and viewed the
stars as the greatest foe
but i could be wrong here
at some point within this timeline radon
who is studying in celia took control of
red main castle to the south while
establishing fort gill in the north now
it could very well be that this castle
was simply gifted to him as he was a
high-ranking noble born of ratigan and
salia sends his sorceress to the academy
of rail lucaria so the son of the master
of the academy and queen of the karyan
line would be a big deal
meanwhile radigan was known as a warrior
of the golden order secretly america and
we see that the worship of america has
spread into caled via the church of the
plague right next to celia and its
graveyard where a statue of america was
erected indicating the golden order
religion had spread here
from redmayne knight ogus ashes we
learned that oga was the longest serving
member of the redmayne knights okus
studied techniques to manipulate gravity
alongside radon
not only does that tell us that radon
took classes under the tutelage of the
alabaster lords alongside others such as
oga but it makes it sound like the red
main knights were actually established
prior to radon coming to kalid and celia
to study
before gaining renown as the star
scourge radon was simply known as
general radon and lead the renbe knights
he gained this title before even
venturing into caleb from karya eskaria
is likely where he befriended jiren
jiren preferred a nomadic existence but
after spending time as a guest of the
karyan royals he became a guest
commander for general radon and for the
first time the restless tumbleweed would
be bound by honorable oath
general radon's army was fashioned after
how he viewed himself a red main lion
warrior similar to godfrey his soldier's
surcoast depicted a red main lion
raising a sword in the image of radon
thus they were red mains and all proved
they were worthy of the name
meanwhile their helmet's visor was
fashioned after a lion's fangs
his knight's armor indicates that he was
indeed proud to be ratigan's son and a
warrior associated with the elite golden
order the red plume is a symbol of
radon's pedigree as lord radigan's son
the mane of the proud red lion and their
red main grey shields bore his crest
grey shield shaped like a fang featuring
the crest of a red main lion radon also
had armorers who served under him with
these armorers cookbooks typically
including recipes for various items
associated with fire
contains knowledge of dealings with
decay the application of fire in
particular
it is interesting that they would use
fire which was so anti-archery but that
will become extremely important later on
similar to his hero godfrey and the
golden lineage radon wanted lions of his
own his own srirachas so once he
established himself at redman castle he
kept two lines within meanwhile once he
established fort gale he also kept a
line there to protect it the symbolism
in red main castle isn't only that of
the golden order though similar to how
karya has a moon gazing grounds with an
extreme association to sorcery magic red
main castle has a very similar moon
gazing grounds with chairs all around
what to me looks to be a moon dial and
something we see commonly associated
with astrology
after taking over kalid and taking on
the stars one of the greatest battles of
all was about to take place
the shattering
this sparked an all-out war between the
various demigods of eldon ring and it
seems like it was here radon suffered a
major defeat and major blow while radon
vied for power and even obtained a great
rune of his own in the intro cutscene we
can see a battle between morgot and
radon with more gods stabbing through
radon making it seem to me that radon
actually fought more god for control
over landel and lost which would lead to
him retreating back to caled
before i go on i've seen a debate that
this character from the image isn't
radon and that the proportions aren't
correct that there are no item
descriptions that speak of this defeat
those are all good points so i decided
to take images of radon's armor as well
as a similar shot of radon with this
head down and combine them to create a
side by side next to this image from the
intro
to me it looks like the same armor set
while there are some minor differences
personally i attribute that to being a
different artist or his scale armor
getting a torn on one arm but not the
other but hey i could be mistaken so i
wanted to present the counterpoint
especially since we're done as far as we
know should be much larger here
for more in-depth discussion on this i
recommend checking out smotown's video
eldon ringlord did margaret defeat radon
it's a really great look into this
around this point godric hid himself
away in stormville castle to avoid any
confrontation with radon honestly
godric's nothing more than a jumped up
country bumpkin
lord what don't make me laugh
first he hid himself amongst the women
folk to flee the capital then hid from
radon in that castle it was then that
another one of the great demigods
decided to march down from the
mountaintops of the giants with her
warriors and take on radon who could
have been her greatest threat
melania
melania took her army of clean rot
knights with her and marched south past
lyrnia through limgrave where she
stomped on godric and indicated for what
would become one of the greatest battles
of the shattering here her soldiers
would have to face off against general
radon soldiers who were all reputed to
be masterful warriors and it was
popularly said that the red mains knew
no weaknesses
radon himself was such a fierce warrior
that what are known as radon spears
arrows he would eventually use for his
lion greypo which was imbued with
gravitational powers of the star scourge
when used along with a radon spear it
becomes a true weapon of a champion
weren't just given the name due to their
size but were actual spears used against
him in battle these are in fact the many
spears with which he was stabbed by the
clean rot knights he who's once called
the strongest of all the demigods
through all of this fighting he even
managed to continue to still hold back
the stars and prevent their cycle from
ever completing
but the true clash was about to begin
radon versus melania
the conqueror of the stars
general radar
and the blade of michela melania vii
these two were the mightiest to remain
and locked horns in combat
but there would be no victor
[Music]
radon was such a fierce competitor that
seems in her exchange with radon melania
resorted to stabbing herself unleashing
the scarlet rod she'd been holding back
in order to win the battle which
resulted in a stalemate
the battle of eonia radon and melania
locked in stalemate then the scarlet
rock blooms
while melania's scarlet rot stopped
radon in his tracks and allowed one of
her soldiers to carry her back to the
halek tree and away from battle it would
have severe repercussions on radon and
caled as a whole
kaelid known as the local of the last
battle between general radon and melania
blade of mikala is a vast land
consummately marred by scarlet rot
the scarlet rot was a contagious disease
that tore apart the land but the red
main knights found a way to try and
contain it
when they were driven to defeat by
melania's scarlet rot the red maid
knights burned the crest on the left
breast of their armor to indicate their
resolve alas dear home i shan't see you
again for our duties to remain here a
bulwark against the blight
his soldiers found that fire was the
solution to the problem of the scarlet
rot general radon the famed red lion and
scourge of the stars is a ferocious
warrior
he fought melania and her wrote to a
standstill in the caled wilds to limb
graves east
and now caleb has been engulfed by the
scarlet rot even approaching the region
is no mean feat
i've heard survivors of radan's army are
still in the wilds staving off the rock
with fire
and if it's true
i suspect radhan is still there as well
in caillou
though i doubt he much resembles his
former self anymore this is where the
redmayne armorer developing fire tools
comes in handy one of these is the
redmayne pot engraved with the crest of
a red main lion even today the survivors
of radon's battalion employ fire to
stave off the scarlet rot these soldiers
also utilize flaming bolts used by
survivors of radon's army to stave off
the scarlet rot
we see evidence of this throughout caled
in particular the calem ruins houses
piles of bodies burnt to a crisp with
mechanical fire shooting contraptions
watching over them ready to burn
anything else that passes by
the jail cave located near fort gale
contains prisoners who have now also
been burnt to a crisp it's unclear if
these prisoners were locked away after
developing scarlet rot and therefore put
in prison away from other people as a
safety measure just in case they had
scarlet rot and to prevent it from
spreading which could have potentially
included any number of their enemies
including melania's clean rot knights
but as they're all burnt to crisp it's
hard to say they've created burnt
fortifications throughout the
disease-infested caled where they fight
off against giant mutated and diseased
beasts burning away their remains to
fight the disease until the end finally
jiren and the red main soldiers decide
to hold a festival of war for general
radon
convene the festival of war honor
general radon with the warriors glory is
in your hands sir jaren
while rodon had ended the battle with
melania and a stalemate with no true
victors he still contracted scarlet rot
but even with scarlet rot this fierce
warrior still lives on he still
internally fought against the scarlet
roth with this great rune stating the
great rune burns to resist the
encroachment of the scarlet rot
before we begin
allow me to paint you the full picture
general radar is cursed ever to wander
eaten from the inside by melania's
scarlet rot his wits are long gone
now he gathers the corpses of former
friends and foes alike
gorging on them
like a dog
as it turns out general radon wasn't
just a great warrior and soldier but it
also earned his soldiers respect to the
highest extent rather than trying to
snipe him out they held a festival in
his honor to give him an honorable death
jiren served general radon as a guest
commander and they are said to have
sworn an oath of honorable death to one
another
champions
welcome
the stars of aligned
the festival is nigh
general radon
mightiest demigod of the shattering
awaits you the general was blighted by
scarlet rot and driven to madness
but not long ago he was hailed as the
mightiest demigod of them all and
radon's renowned as a great warrior was
now known all throughout the lands with
champions of all kinds choosing to
partake in this festival out of respect
for radon
by the by
do you know for whom this festival is
being held
well
it is none other than general radar
himself
to think
i could face a great champion of the
shattering
a demigod in the flesh
oh god
in truth i quiver at the thought such is
his frightful repute and the amazing
thing is even going insane even mad from
scarlet rot radon still managed to
continue using his gravity powers to
stay by his steed side and he still
managed to continue holding back the
stars which had earned him his nickname
of the star scourge it's only after
defeating general radon you can witness
for yourself what he was holding back
did you see that afterwards a falling
star right before our eyes
i can't fathom how radan was holding
back something of that scale
he was a living legend if ever i saw one
for defeating radon you set back in
motion ronnie's questline but more
importantly you put to rest one of the
most respected generals to exist in the
lands between who earned the respect of
those he commanded and renown amongst
the populace
at last
the war festival has ended
brave champion
you have our gratitude
the celebration was spectacular
general radan is surely pleased
festering with rot and crippled by
madness
all he wanted
was an honorable death
[Music]
that wraps up this lore video on
starstruck radon and kalid i'd love to
know your theories regarding radon's
intentions on holding back the stars and
if there's anything you think i might
have missed these are always discussions
and i encourage you to watch other lore
videos and come to your own conclusions
if you enjoyed this i've already made
videos on ranala and the academy of rail
lucaria as well as godric so please
consider checking those out and i'll see
you guys next time
peace
[Music]